now on to the weather were a
record-breaking storm hammering the
Northeast is causing trouble for
millions of people this morning
this storm is blamed for at least eight
deaths as it pushed across more than 30
states during this past week right now
conditions they are still bad in eastern
New England where some areas could see a
total of two feet of snow by the end of
the storm this afternoon
yikes Don Dahler is in Keene New
Hampshire Don a lot of people are crying
uncle this morning so how are the
conditions there yeah I'm crying uncle
along with them to be completely it's
actually still snowing here in Keene and
there is at least a foot on the ground
maybe a little bit more but as you can
see the lights are on here whereas
through much of the Northeast about
80,000 people are without power now some
folks are starting to dig out but others
believe it or not remain in the path of
this powerful storm this snow came in
hard and furious
we were just freezing people coast to
coast or enduring the wrath of a
relentless storm finally on its way out
it's really about everyone should just
really be careful but not before
slamming the country with more heavy
snow it's raining Dennis snowing it's
raining Dennis no rain if we didn't have
a wood stove we wouldn't survive there's
no heat here power outages and bitter
cold first responders and plow trucks
are working around the clock to clear
accidents and roads they were deploying
our assets as we can best determine by
those forecasts New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo declared a state of emergency in
several counties it's above Interstate
90 in New Lebanon was shut down after a
bus carrying about 30 people collided
with the tractor-trailer no one was
seriously injured it was one of more
than 700 crashes reported in New York
couple tractor trailers off the side of
the road in New Hampshire the Manchester
Fire Department's Mike Gamache took us
along to some of the about 100 storm
calls he responded to Monday they look
at most of the buildings when I go by
and make sure nobody stranded or there's
no trees down wires up to two feet of
snow is expected on the ground in some
New England areas I was supposed to go
to work today
hi boss but some people like Coleen
banister say they will be ready number
one we're smart enough to stay off the
roads when it's bad number two we're
usually pretty good about cleaning it up
but number three is I like that our
neighbors help each other out it started
snowing here in New Hampshire about 3
p.m. Sunday
now it's due to stop here in the next
few hours but around Boston along the
coast they could get another half foot
of snow by lunchtime and despite what it
looks like here you have to keep in mind
the official start of winter is still 18
days away Anthony nobody told winter to
come early done thank you it sure looks
pretty